guys I want to explain real quick right
off the top why I head faked you a
little bit you know had a head fake you
a little bit like Brian Rose even
sometimes I have to kind of head fake
you a little bit because I said I wasn't
gonna talk about Brian rose again and
obviously here we are let me first
explain why guys cuz honestly truly you
have to believe me I didn't intend to
make another video about Brian Rose but
he kind of I don't want to say he
addressed us cuz it's kind of like a
vague you know jab but he took a dig at
coffee Zilla he took a dig at all of his
critics in a recent video where he
responds to this vais article that was
written about him now if you don't know
if you haven't seen it already
vice just tore Brian a new one in this
article they did and Brian responded to
it and tried to spin it as if oh no this
doesn't hurt me you can't you can't harm
me vice you're just the BBC and in this
video I will get into the specifics in a
second he says something about how he's
ok with criticism and he's happy to
respond to criticism which is such a lie
he does not want to respond to criticism
and everything is about creating the
illusion of transparency with you guys
because look if you guys go back to
Brian roses meltdown he doesn't believe
in transparency you see it in his post
he goes transparency was never my aim
that was when Brian was you know being
open with people but then he changed he
did a 180 right he realized that wasn't
gonna work because his audience was
gonna have that so then he puts on this
illusion of transparency where he posts
a video for example giving the truth
about the digital freedom platform where
he answers none of the substantial
criticisms against him and instead just
kind of blow v'h for thirty minutes but
this takes it to another level because
what he says here is this look I'm happy
to respond to criticism but check this
out there's a caveat he has a little
caveat I'm always happy to respond to
criticism from credible media sources
there we have it you see if you hear
that I'm happy to respond to criticism
I'm credible media sources incredible
media sources right which basically
means he's happy to respond to criticism
from anyone he deems to be a credible
media source but then get this after
calling vice a credible media source who
basically regurgitates the arguments
I've been
telling you about four weeks and doesn't
even get to all of them he then goes and
says you can't trust vice because
they're just like the BBC vice I'm a bit
disappointed and who you've become it's
just something that I think it's turned
into more of something that's like the
BBC that's what it feels like it feels
like mainstream media to me in in the
title of his thing he says vice is
incredible because they're just
mainstream news now while also saying
he'll only respond to comment and
criticism from mainstream news did he
catch that he's on the one hand saying
mainstream news is incredible it's
absolutely bogus anything they say vice
is just like the rest of them you know
they're lying but also will refuse to
respond to criticism from non mainstream
sources from independent sources like me
but let's say you're Brian let's say you
don't want to respond to me because you
don't consider me a journalist okay I
won't take that as a dig I won't take
that as a dig and let's say you also
think the Vice is incredible because
they're just like the BBC now well what
if we had a beautiful balance of those
two things what if we had a youtuber who
is independent and an independent
journalist but also they had mainstream
journalism experience so they're
definitely a journalist and they're also
definitely independent would you respond
to I don't know rebel wisdom who's
contacted you six times with real
criticisms to you to your platform no no
Brian won't do that because Brian isn't
transparent like he wants you to believe
he is and so this I'm not gonna lie it
triggered me a little bit and I realized
you know this guy I can't not respond
because it's such a blatant lie to his
audience that oh yeah me me Brian I'm
fine with being criticized I'm happy to
respond to criticism but he's not and he
lies in this piece because look here's
one thing Brian says he says I responded
because I want to respond to criticism
of me right I'm transparent Brian
transparent London real we respond to
all the criticisms of me I responded to
each point of vice so I responded to
every single one of their questions and
replied back but that is not true in the
first like few paragraphs of this thing
right here I asked
rose via email why he denied freedom of
speech from commenters but he did not
address the question in his response so
right off the bat Brian roses lying
about his transparency he's not being
transparent because he does not respond
to criticism from credible news sources
because look call me not credible
whatever but don't go after rebel wisdom
don't say you responding to criticism
from credible sources
when rebel wisdoms out here criticizing
you and you don't respond a comment but
also while calling vice a credible news
source also basically discount
everything they have to say by calling
them too mainstream right and don't stay
here a hundred percent transparent
you're answering all their questions
when clearly you're not addressing
questions he emits very serious
criticisms of him like this one like
Brian Rose's total hypocrisy with
freedom of speech he's the digital
freedom platform guy but he himself
censors comments he himself will block
people like how ironic can you get and
yet while maintaining the illusion of
transparency he doesn't respond to this
very basic criticism of him and I just
wanted to bring your attention to this
because I think it's really important to
understand that the values Brian
proclaims to be for he's for them when
it benefits him so he's for freedom of
speech and he calls himself in this
piece an absolutist for free speech he
goes on about this he gives himself
several paths in the back he almost
breaks his arm
patting himself on the back um they
called me an absolutist when it comes to
freedom of speech as if that's a bad
thing you're damn right I'm an
absolutist but at the same time we know
he's censoring comments so what is it
Brian which is it are you an absolutist
for free speech or are you for censoring
comments and taking down any speech that
is in your house right
like the cognitive dissonance that is
required to hold these two things at the
same time I'm gonna censor comments but
I'm also gonna say I'm at an absolutist
for free speech it's I don't understand
how it lives with this and then guys the
most recent thing came out and I have to
talk about this so because I don't want
to make a lot of videos extra videos on
Brian Rose like I said I want to be done
with it but he keeps he keeps setting me
off boys he keeps sort of taking jabs at
us and you
what when he does that we have to
respond he also posted this thing about
how his TED talk is banned on YouTube
with 1 million views why freedom of
speech no longer exists and basically
he's pissed off that Ted removed videos
from their YouTube page like it wasn't
YouTube they removed them Ted themselves
decided look we don't want this guy on
her platform anymore because of the
stuff he's saying in other platforms now
Brian Rose takes huge issue with this
and he says you know what you're taking
away my rights you're violating my
rights
I want my human rights now so Ted please
put my talk back up so other people can
enjoy it you know I will not allow you
to take away my human rights ok so I
want to be clear here he's claiming a
certain position right and we're gonna
hold him to that standard cuz he's
claims to be for a certain value and
that value is when you post a speech
with someone else online you then
shouldn't take it down when new facts
come to light about that person right
he's mad that Ted had his talk on and
then they took it off that's what he's
mad about me saying freedom of speech no
longer exists this is not right
and he makes a whole video ranting about
how it's unfair but guess who also
removes talks at his own discretion
Brian Rose when it benefits him remember
Peter sage you know the guy we we had a
whole debate with on our channel where
is that talk where is that interview
well when you click on it it says that
video no longer exists on brian's
channel you won't find it why I don't
know because Brian at his own discretion
for whatever reason it doesn't really
matter said I don't want this guy on my
platform so which is it is Brian for
free speech does he want his TED talk to
be on Ted platform regardless of what he
does in the future you're damn right I'm
an absolutist you know I will not allow
you to take away my human rights or does
he also want to have Peter sages Talk
taken off of his youtube channel because
of what he did this is just blatant
classic hypocrisy and the fact that he
tried to discredit you know myself and
rebel wisdom as oh we're just
non-credible you know news sources I'm
always happy to respond to criticism
from credible media sources oh I'm only
gonna respond to the stuff I like
because anything I don't respond to it's
just it's just discredited
it's just discredited news sources well
at the same time saying oh yeah Pais
who's vice vice is just the BBC how can
we trust bys
and it just shows that you have now
become part of the mainstream media's
I'll respond to bites because they're
the only credible news sources talked
about me but at the same time vice is
incredible because you know what they're
just they're just the BBC how dare they
they're just the BBC you know what guys
I just wanted to make this quick
response because a lot of you have been
just talking to me asking me to respond
to this whole vice piece and yeah I'll
just say disappointed with Brian's
response because once again it shows
that he's unwilling to face the real
criticism and again criticisms he hasn't
answered why did you spend forty
thousand dollars on your own London real
platform when you said the digital
freedom platform would be independent
why aren't you using [ __ ] who he says
it's because [ __ ] who doesn't have live
streaming but why do you need live
streaming is live streaming worth
spending millions of dollars of your
supporters money when you claim to be
frugal why are you censoring comments
when you proclaim to be a free speech
absolutist why aren't you responding to
rebel wisdom a real journalist who's an
independent media source when you claim
that vice is too mainstream why aren't
you responding to independent news is it
because you don't find independent news
credible or is that that you're just
playing a game you're playing a game
with your subscribers and you're trying
to only respond to stuff that puts you
in a positive light with them ultimately
that's it guys that's my quick rant on
that sorry to bring this back up we're
done we're done for sure and I'm
definitely not head faking you this time
and you know what no no we're talking
about Brian Rose we'll never have
another video about Pratt Rhinos maybe
maybe sometimes I got that even
sometimes I have to kind of head fake
you a little bit and don't forget to
smash like and subscribe thank you
[Music]
rebut any criticism federal sources
[Music]
any presentations
[Music]